- Let's finish things up
(audience clapping)
with a story of hope on this Friday.
This is what I'm liking.
- Yeah!
(audience cheering)
Jilted brides.
It is a stuff of many rom-coms
and I want you to see
how one British woman
made the most of her wedding day,
just hours after learning the groom
would not be making an appearance.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
I mean, that is literally,
we are watching lemons
being turned into lemonade
with tequila.
(audience laughs)
We have her on the line now.
I cannot wait to talk to her.
Dialed in from Wales.
What's up Kayley?
(audience cheering)
- Hi! Thank you so much for having me.
- No, absolutely!
Oh my gosh, you are a
half glass full girl.
So I think most brides
would be devastated.
How did you bounce back?
- To be fair, it was just more
about what the day become.
It was learning what true kind of self is
and that's what true love is
and kind of like, and self-love.
That's what I learned from that day,
and kind of, so...
What happened?
So me and my groom, my ex,
basically planned this
wedding day for two years,
and me and my girlfriends
were in an Airbnb the night before,
and we woke up with so much girl energy,
and we were getting ready, and kind of,
I put my like Charlotte
Tilbury foundation on
and any girl knows that it's
expensive and it's beautiful.
So I was kind of ready to get that on,
and I spoke to his dad,
who informed me that,
unfortunately, my ex wouldn't be able,
basically wouldn't come
and didn't wanna come.
And I was about to get
married in an hour and a half.
And
- My gosh!
I spoke with my sister,
I know! I spoke with my sister
and she kind of dusted me
off and we decided that,
I decided I still wanted to enjoy the day
because I worked my
socks off for this day,
and I was excited to
spend time with my friends
and my family and I was looking
forward to the nacho bar
and the food and the
cheese and the jalapenos.
And it just turned
(Kelly laughing)
into this incredible day.
- We can totally be friends
(Kayley laughing)
just from you having a nacho bar.
So tell us about your
re-imagined wedding though.
Like how did it go?
Because I can imagine like,
everyone there probably
took their cue from you
like emotionally where you
were, like what was going on,
but also that's, it's an intense moment.
So how did it all play out?
- Yeah, it was hard
like for anybody there,
so like guests, myself, my friends,
my family, it was hard overall.
But once I got down there
after getting kind of redone,
I had my sister and my best friend
go into the room to tell the guests.
They came out into the kind of courtyard
and I walked around the bush.
We gave a kind of a massive
hug, massive cuddle.
Everyone had a bit of a cry.
And then I said, "Let's do this."
And we walked into the marquee.
I walked in with my
bride and the groomsmen
and we walked into Lizzo's "Good as Hell,"
which was just amazing.
I think that set the tone
- Yeah.
for the day.
And I just made sure that the
playlist was turned around.
So we had like independent
divas, like really iconic songs,
like you, for example, like your song,
like, "What Doesn't Kill
You Makes You Stronger,"
was just the epitome of the day,
- Awww!
if that makes any sense.
(audience cheering)
And it was just, like, incredible.
I got a dance with my dad,
my brothers and my mum,
and I even punched the top
of my wedding cake off.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
And it was just
a day that I will always remember
with like, pure happiness
in a strange way.
- I know, but way to-
I mean, it just says
a lot about your heart
and your character and your mindset.
Like, way to turn that around and go-
'Cause honestly, like you
don't want that dude to show up
if he didn't wanna be there.
You know what I'm saying?
You don't want to be,
- No.
and he don't deserve you.
The fact that you could
have spent a lifetime
with someone who could
take something devastating
and turn that around.
Like, that's incredibly
hard to do in a relationship
when times are hard,
and when times are hard,
you seem like a person
that is so resilient.
Thank you so much, Kayley.
I love you and I'm liking
your post right now.
- Thank you.
(bell dings)
Thank you so much.
(audience cheering)
(Kayley laughing)
- And that's not all, Kayley.
Our season-long partner
Pilot, pen makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate your
positive approach and spirit.
So they're giving you a thousand
dollars just for being you.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much! What?
Absolutely! Thank you, Kayley!
- Thank you!
Have a wonderful 2023
(audience cheering)
and thank you to all our guests this hour.
Marcia Gay Harden, Storm Reid,
Holly Laessig, Jess Wolf,
Sophie and Ryan.
(audience cheering)
Y'all have a great day.
If it's not, be like Kayley.
(audience cheering)
Just change it!